[Music]
as the pandemic drags on people around
the world are bracing for
still more months stuck at home until a
vaccine goes
into widespread use but in japan people
are going to great lengths to get out of
the house and as lucy craft reports from
tokyo
for some remote workers the sky
is the limit working from home
month after month can give you a bad
case of cabin fever
but now japan has found the antidote to
workplace monotony
getting taken for a ride on a ferris
wheel
converted to airborne office cubicles
yomiuri land amusement
park outside tokyo now rents office
space with the ultimate stunning views
free wi-fi but laptop and office water
cooler
not included spokesman yoo okutani said
lots of users told us the time just flew
by
18 buys you a lounge chair poolside
and one hour in rotation up to 500 feet
in the air
among the 150 takers so far were seiji
acai and his wife the online events
manager boarded a cabin for his first
gravity-defying conference call
my coworkers said it looked like i was
on vacation they were jealous he said
the amusement park has dozens of rides
but very few needless to say
are suited to desk work the roller
coaster and merry-go-round aren't laptop
friendly the spokesman said
we advise customers to ride these when
they take a break from work
meanwhile japan has thousands of cheap
rent-by-the-hour karaoke rooms
these days they're being repurposed at a
big
echo karaoke outlet in downtown tokyo
demand is growing not from
warblers but from white collar workers
meeting in this super ventilated karaoke
room instead of a coffee shop
these workers said there was just one
drawback
when we file our expense report it's
going to look like we were loafing said
this employee
and whenever work gets too intense you
can always pick up a microphone
and belt out some tunes for cbs this
morning saturday
lucy craft tokyo